this is Jimmy Fallon and this is the
Tonight Show Home Edition I'm gonna
shoot a mini monologue everyday welcome
to my bathroom the show must go on and
the late-night host our social
distancing during the corona virus
outbreak Stephen Colbert who started the
late-night quarantine Monday night
delivered a monologue from his bathtub
soup and tie included we need to slow
the spread of this virus epidemiologists
call this flattening the curve but based
on my current level of an activity in
stress-baking
I definitely will not be flattening my
curves Jimmy Fallon joined in on the fun
and hosted the Tonight Show from the
comfort of his own home welcome to
tonight's show I'm so excited to be
doing the show from my panic room I mean
I mean living room of course there's no
audience well there is an audience my
wife but shouldn't really laugh at
everything did I say coming to us live
the late night hosts hilariously played
acoustic to celebrate st. Patrick's Day
so kiss me I'm Irish but stay six feet
away cuz no one wants to get a virus on
st. Patty's Day
also celebrating the holiday was Jimmy
Kimmel who rock all green while working
from home you know you learn a lot about
yourself when you're isolated at home
for instance I learned that I have two
young children I'm actually hiding in my
office right now from my children we've
run out of snacks we've run out of
crafts to do we made macaroni necklaces
yesterday today I ate them for lunch
that's how bad it's getting the cutest
part of Kimmel's mini log was his new
graphics department aka his
five-year-old daughter Jane who made a
series of drawings for the opening but
up up on a bumper tapa but I bought
better pop on oppa Jimmy Kimmel Live
it's a--let's meanwhile it was day two
for Colbert who discovered fire in his
own backyard
we're calling it tonight the flame show
was Stephen Colbert cut to his
bandleader Jon batiste who helped him
with a rendition of Danny Boy for st.
Paddy's Danny Boy your hands you're also
singing a rendition Conan O'Brien he
belted out in his kitchen as he
performed a hand washing tutorial with
Guinness Jameson and Lucky Charms Oh dad
you know what it's too stupid it's just
you stupid my apologies and the Today
show must go on Savannah Guthrie works
from home after coming down with a sore
throat things look a little different I
feel a little lonely here
I'm missing my partner in crime she's
usually six feet away here but Miss
Guthrie where are you I wasn't feeling
my best little sore throats and sniffles
I wouldn't have thought anything of it
but we are in different times aren't we
[Music]